[Applause]
ned flanders
how's it going bros my name is peter
pack you may know me as a man
that carries no regrets because i've
done nothing wrong
in my entire life so let's laugh at
other fools
while they go oh shouldn't have done
that because i don't know what that
feels like
whatsoever okay let's go
hockey player thinks his penalty is
[ __ ] until he watches a replay
okay
[Music]
nice wait what
what the [ __ ] what kind of camp is this
never made that
mistake that dude trying so hard not to
look at her be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
again
third time's a charm you can do it
that's a bad day that's literally a bad
day
that's all it took that's all it took
chad energy what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh bro you ain't ready
oh no i have leg day later it's gonna be
me i know it
is that yeah yeah i can up the weight so
i've i've
i've done enough reps you know i
sniffing broccoli
being a morning person
ah that's gotta hurt ah go back home
oh that's actually how i got i don't
know if you can see this
yeah you can i got a scar exactly like
that i was in austria
i was 18. it was 3 a.m at a nightclub
i heard a song i liked i skipped down to
the dance floor and exactly this
happened to me
it was the most weirdest experience of
my life just
having to walk through the whole place
bleeding from my head
and then the most buffish guy i've ever
seen in my life comes
let me through i'm a nurse let me look
at him
like what the [ __ ] everyone thought i
had been in that fight or something
[Music]
man's got super strength this is why you
don't open doors for other people
i keep saying it monkey monkey
oh my god don't [ __ ] with monkey
i keep saying it i've said it my whole
life
this is why they ask you not to touch
[Music]
yeah yeah you're helping congratulations
keep your hands off it lady
you've done enough
let's pour water on it that'll ah jesus
oh don't do that
[Music]
oh no no he stretched his neck
oh [ __ ] i could hear that
oh no no no
no uh and that's why your amazon
delivery didn't arrive on time
oh my god oh my god it just hurts
doesn't it
oh god not jim stuff
oh no that's gonna
[Music]
that guy keeps gotta finish this set
first
then maybe i'll help her what the [ __ ]
are you serious
i gotta finish oh
dude i swear i was on my 11th i was
going to finish
what the [ __ ] guy on pec
deck pause not to help but to catch his
breath because it's chest day dammit yes
amazing how do you [ __ ] this up
he's gonna get no
no oh
god oh my ah
ah that's no next please
please
i've seen this it's beautiful three
times
oh you got him
oh yes life is cruel
this is the whole subreddit is just
awful
someone's gonna open the door
she's fine she's fine don't worry
how do you not realize you're walking on
white cement dude
oh sorry oh sorry was i oh sorry let me
just continue okay sorry
monkey
the disbelief of what he's just done
unbelievable
trying to steal a necklace let me guess
the door is locked behind him
yep oh oh about that oh i forgot the
necklace
oh my bad
all right i just uh what do you do
he got arrested
[Laughter]
oh god is okay this is a swedish thing
again it's super streaming it's this uh
rotten fish that people eat
during mid-summer for some reason you
need to open it under water so this
because the stink is it's just i can't
imagine opening that in a car
you will die you will literally die it
is seen as a terrorist weapon
it is classified i'm not even joking
that's how bad it smells
press open things no i didn't think it
was do i need a can opener
haha don't do it here we go
what's happening
oh that's the worst snow i've ever
thought about
i can't think of a worse place that car
will smell forever
like you cannot clean out that smell oh
god
oh what a shame what a lost opportunity
he would have looked alphas
if he just kept walking all right that's
it
for instant regret hope you enjoyed this
video look at craft
look at graf i see you guys tomorrow
profess
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and
interesting topics but then there is one
subject
that we somehow missed welcome home my
tuber friends
every home is different and love is
central to every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings
[Music]